hey this is presh talwalker every
student at ranmore College selected one
language French or Mandarin and one
science subject chemistry or physics
60 students chose physics and Mandarin
100 students chose chemistry
twice as many students chose French as
chose Mandarin
120 students selected either physics or
Mandarin but not both
how many students are there at randmore
college
this is a very interesting logic puzzle
and when I received it I was told only
three percent of all students in
Singapore taking the competition
correctly solved this question
can you figure it out pause the video if
you'd like to give this problem a try
and when you're ready keep watching to
learn how to solve this problem
[Music]
let's get started with the information
that twice as many students chose French
as Mandarin
so let's say the total number of
students that chose Mandarin is X then
the total number of students that chose
French is 2x so we'll put this into the
table
now 120 students selected either physics
or Mandarin but not both
so we're looking at physics French and
chemistry Mandarin
so there's a total between these two
cells of 120 students so if one of the
cells let's say physics French is y then
the other cell chemistry Mandarin will
be 120 minus y
now let's take a look at this table
the total number of students studying
physics will be 60 plus y
French plus Mandarin will be 2x plus X
since all students study French or
Mandarin the total number of students at
Rand Moore College will be the total of
these which is 3x
but we can also look at the total number
of students that study chemistry or
physics and that will also be the total
number of students so we have that 3x is
equal to 160 plus y
now let's look at the total number of
students that study Mandarin
this will be 180 minus y but we also
know that this is equal to X so we have
X is equal to 180 minus y
we will now add up these two equations
to cancel out the Y variable so we get
4X is equal to 340.
we want the total number of students
which is represented as 3x so we
multiply both sides of this equation by
three over four and that gives that 3x
is equal to 340 times 3 over 4 which is
equal to
255. thus there are 255 students at
randmore college and that's the answer
thanks for making us one of the best
communities on YouTube see you next
episode of mind your decisions where we
solve The World's problems one video at
a time
foreign